connaissez vous remercie d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors on
voit bien que mohammad bin salman craint
d'avoir les mains liées dans ses futurs
rapports avec les états unis
l'accélération de ses procès contre les
opposants politiques en sont la preuve
selon vous non je ne suis pas convaincu
par cet argumentaire d'abord parce que
complet rappelez vous que quand top
était en pleine campagne électorale lui
aussi avait désigné l'arabie saoudite
comme un pays avec lequel il fallait
normaliser les relations en tout cas les
banaliser et rendre comment dire à leurs
habits saoudite statut différent de
celui qui avait été le jusque là la lie
à privilégier cela dit dès qu'il a été
élu son premier voyage officiel s'est
fait en arabie saoudite
et vous avez vous même vous montrer les
images où il présentait les effets des
contrats commerciaux d'armement signés
avec ryad donc l'idée comme candidat à
la maison blanche puisse critiquer
l'arabie saoudite pendant sa campagne
électorale n'est pas un fait nouveau
donc la question c'est est-ce que byden
va pour autant avoir une ligne
stratégique différente
ça chante la diplomatie américaine
continue toujours à considérer que c'est
l'iran le facteur déstabilisant du
moyen-orient dont je n'y croit qu'à
moitié
d'autre part je ferai remarquer que la
répression n'a jamais cessé en arabie
saoudite
en 2008 c'était huit blogueurs qui était
arrêté en 2002 pendant 2018 c'était aux
femmes en 2019 cédé huit blogueurs et
tout à coup maintenant parce qu'on
approchera des élections la pression
s'accentuerait non je n'y crois pas je
crois que c'est une ligne de conduite de
mohamed bin salman pour surtout ne pas
perdre leur les rênes du pouvoir
donc tout individu comme par exemple
jaenada toulouse cette jeune fille qui
avait simplement conduit alors qu'elle
n'avait pas le droit et qui se retrouve
encore aujourd'hui dans un procès dans
un avec une grève de la faim avec de la
torture etc
bon les autres sont aussi alors qu'un
facteur important des citoyens à double
nationalité
c'est à dire les gens qui ont aussi la
nationalité américaine donc c'est un
moyen de faire pression sur washington
pour dire attention j'ai aussi quelques
cartes en main et donc je doute si vous
voulez que baye donne change
complètement la ligne diplomatique de
washington à l'égard de riols une autre
des promesses de giovanna c'est la
suspension des bombes
d'armes en raison des bavures répétées
notamment au yémen
vous pensez que le futur locataire de la
maison blanche peut tenir sa promesse
non je dis je dis grand pas qui croit
parce que l'arabie saoudite est un
immense marché d'armement n'oubliez pas
que même la france l'arabie saoudite est
le meilleur client des armements
français depuis en moyenne lissée si
vous voulez sur une depuis une vingtaine
d'années donc arriver à convaincre vos
industriel avec l'amplifier période de
récession économique qu'on est en train
de connaître il faut cesser les ventes
d'armes à l'arabie saoudite non on va
sans doute faire quelques mises en garde
en disant non non vous fournira pas tel
équipement parce qu'il est trop
meurtriers et serra enfin n'oubliez pas
que toute la logique de renseignements
il fourni par les états unis draguer
royer man donc si les saoudiens tir mal
et tuent des civils
c'est à partir de renseignements qui
sont fournies par les américains donc
dire qu'on va suspendre et arrêter les
vendeurs non je n'y crois pas alors vous
n'avez vu les etats unis gardent plus ou
moins la même ligne politique même si
les présidents se succèdent est ce que
l'objectif de joe biden ça sera vraiment
d'effacer l'héritage de donald trump en
arabie saoudite dans tous les présidents
ont pas eu la même ligne rappelez vous
quand même qu'obama avait fait les
quelques discours très très critique sur
l'arabie saoudite et trump a au
contraire a rétabli la normalité de la
relation donc je pense qu'effectivement
baydan peut avoir quelques prises de
position un peu critique à l'égard du
yémen à l'encontre de quelques opposants
saoudiens notamment des citoyens
américains qui sont en prison n'oubliez
pas quand même qu'il ya 3 3 citoyens des
doubles nationaux ce que vous voulez
qu'ils sont actuellement emprisonnés
avec les menaces sur des faits qui sont
totalement aberrant parce que
effectivement je prends l'exemple du de
ce médecin
je vais le procès à la haye dit et il
est arrêté simplement parce que il a
exprimé un point de vue sur les
révolutions arabes parce qu'ils
demandent qu'on résolve la crise avec le
qatar et ses rangs mais dans le même
moment si vous voulez et saoudiens
mettre en prison des religieux notamment
des religieux qui demande des réformes à
lahoud à qui est actuellement en prison
réparé à laoudar salman al aouda ouais
c'est ça qui est en prison
et quelque chose qui est assez étonnant
c'est quelqu'un qui après appartenait au
mouvement de la sarre fois c'est à dire
de ce mouvement réformateur qui avait
suivi la guerre du golfe et c'est parce
qu'il est un réformateur qui est en
prison
donc si vous voulez dire que l'arabie
saoudite accents sinon c'est une espèce
de logique de fonctionnement
mohammed bin salman et pas simplement
beaucoup plus brutale parce que la
société saoudienne tiraille un peu dans
tous les sens donc vous vous attendez à
plus d'isolement de l'arabie saoudite
avec l'herbe hayden que nous avec quatre
ans une phase de crise qui sera
temporaire mais les intérêts américains
en arabie saoudite et les intérêts
saoudiens aux états unis sont énormes
si les saoudiens décidé de retirer tous
leurs actifs aux états unis on aurait
probablement une crise économique bien
plus grave
donc chacun des deux si vous voulez se
tient par la barbichette en face du
formel au mondial de la communication a
été remis mais si vous voulez les
intérêts des deux pays sont extrêmement
importantes et donc je ne crois pas une
minute que bayonne va véritablement
basculer complètement la politique
économique et la politique jacques
terral à l'égard de riols merci beaucoup
à pierre conesa d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
spécialisé question stratégique
international et ancien haut
fonctionnaire